well we have footage for you that was
filmed this morning in northern spain it
shows moments of panic on a train that
was traveling from the capital madrid to
the city of feral
the train stopped because of wildfires
and passengers were able to see the
flames on both sides from the train
windows
actually imagine that was a terrifying
experience for those involved let's
speak to skye siobhan robbins now who
joins me from cabernet in france and
siobhan this is happening across europe
talk to me about what's happening where
you are today
yeah it's absolutely baking uh here in
france by 11 o'clock this morning it was
35 degrees i've actually joined you here
from a village that's been evacuated
already so you can see it's very quiet
in the background there are volunteers
coming in and out just checking the
houses they've told us actually as soon
as we've finished speaking to you we
need to get out as well because it isn't
safe this is one of the areas where the
fire is being blown towards essentially
so we've seen fire crews coming in and
out of this car park filling up getting
some refreshments of course it's
vacantly hot for them as well we've
actually gone out to the front line of
one of the fires this morning and it's
you can see how difficult the job is the
fires are embedded deep in these pine
forests and as soon as the wind changes
you suddenly see this big blanket of red
coming towards you as the wall of flames
move through the forest and then they'll
change again and go back in the other
direction and so what the firefighters
are really trying to do is contain them
by either clearing paths for them or
dropping fire retardant liquid from
planes onto them as well there are two
main fires that are being fought here uh
one in this area one closer to a lake
and a beach more than sixteen 000 people
have been evacuated from their homes in
this area we know there are more than uh
1 700 firefighters involved in this and
the temperatures just keep on ramping up
they were really hoping to have got this
under control by today because they said
this is a heat apocalypse which is
facing france today
every single city by lunchtime we were
told was going to be at least 30 degrees
in temperature it is absolutely sizzling
here they're hoping for some respite in
the next few days but to be honest i
spoke to an official today as we drove
to those fires and i said how long do
you think you're going to be fighting
them and she said possibly for up to two
more weeks
siobhan it's an absolutely desperate
situation thank you very much for the
update and sean robbins there talking to
us from france